this is a production of Cornell
University
alright Thank You heralds and thank you
everyone for being here based on the
presence I'm assuming we have some
coffee lovers or soil health lovers or
both or neither which is fine you're
probably here because you're taking a
class and you need to be here but I'm
hoping that it'll be an insightful
presentation so to give you some
background information about coffee
production in in Colombia almost all of
our coffee that we consume is produced
by small holder farmers in Colombia and
it's been increasingly challenging for
them to keep up with production and earn
a consistent income because of the price
of fluctuations the market price
fluctuations as you can see from the
1972 2006-16 you see drastic changes
which makes you know an inconsistent
income for farmers the other issue is
drastic changes in climate trends this
was an article in The Guardian about two
and a half months ago about how climate
change is predicted to have coffee
growing area that supports these small
holder farmers so soil health actually
can be a solution in a sense that it may
offer coffee farmers on marketing
advantage and significant price premiums
by promoting sustainability the ftp here
which is the Fairtrade proof is just one
example of an organization that provides
price premiums based on social economic
and environmental sustainability and
sometimes these price premiums can be so
high to be double what your regular
commodity price is so the purpose of
this multidisciplinary study so the
purpose of this multidisciplinary study
is to identify the characteristics of
soil health in Colombian coffee systems
to better address the issues of economic
social and environmental sustainability
so the outline is so the multiplet study
consists of three parts the first part
is
very sociological anthropological based
study that consists of understanding
soil health and associated farmers
perception and Colombian coffee systems
the second part is to determine the
association between coffee cup quality
and soil health and the third part is a
comparative analysis of the different
regional scoring frameworks so our study
was located in six municipality 'he's
within the department of Calca
department is equivalent to state so the
kalke is located in the southwest part
of colombia and farms in the each
municipality either belonged to the
local coffee co-op or didn't belong so
they were members or non-member farms
from the member farms to soil samples
were collected a most the most fertile
sample as indicated by the farmer so we
went to the farm and we told him ok we
want you to identify in your farm the
most fertile for type lot and we sampled
that and excuse me and the least for
tile and the same thing as indicated by
the farmer and then a representative
sample one representative sample was
collected from the non-member farms so
this this is this is what was this is
what this is great information for to
assess the procession of farmers of soil
health so the samples were collected
they were they were sent to the soil
health lab here and I'm a number of
physical chemical and biological
indicators were measured physical
indicators included what aggregate
stability which is measured measured
using a rainfall simulator which
delivers 12.5 milliliter millimeters of
water in five minutes an available water
capacity which is which is measured
using pressure chambers that extract
water at two different pressures the 10
kilo pascal and the 15 kilo pascal
biological indicators included organic
matter which which is measured
based on Lawson ignition active carbon
which is measured with potassium
permanganate oxidation and measured with
a 550 nanometers spectrophotometer soil
respiration measured by capturing co2
and a four day incubation using
potassium hydroxide and the soil protein
index was which is extracted with a
citrate buffer under high temperature
and pressure finally the chemical
indicators included pH measured in a
one-to-one water slurry phosphorus
potassium and the micronutrients were
all extracted with modified Morgan and
quantified by with the ICP so the whole
the songhouse scoring was was was
undertaken using a cumulative normal
distribution so the cumulative normal
distribution is the derivative of the
Gaussian distribution the you know the
Gaussian distribution function and it
gives you the probability that a member
of the distribution is less or equal to
your measured soil health indicator for
instance if you look at active carbon
then if we look at the measurement 600
and you derive the distribution it gives
you six hundred would be here it gives
you that the score would be fifty
percent so in some way you can look at
it as a ranking scheme so the parameters
for for MU and Sigma which is the
population mean and in the population
standard deviation we're either
estimated from local conditions and this
was done what where thresholds and
critical values for specifics of how the
indicators have not been established so
in the literature it's nearly impossible
to find the optimum the thresholds or
the optimum levels for available water
capacity organic matter active carbon
protein respiration and phosphorous so
in that case you estimate the population
mean in the in the standard deviation
using the sample mean and the standard
deviation the sample being the N equals
223 for four parameters parameters were
also
determined from existing critical values
found in the literature specific to
coffee soils and hence was the case for
potassium magnesium zinc manganese and
iron wet aggregate stability was the
exception wet aggregate stability when
when you when you plot the distribution
it's very less skewed and that all of
the measurements were on the high end
they were 90 and so we used the measured
values as the scores themselves because
the measured values is a percent based
measurement so we use that those are
scores and then overall soil health is
computed as the unweighted arithmetic
mean of individual soil health
indicators meaning that you calculate
the scores for each individual for all
of the indicators and then you take the
main and you get your overall soil
health score so these are what the soil
health scoring curves look like for each
indicator there are two things to note
in this in this graph so there are so
some scoring curves follow a more is
better curve which is the case for the
following and then some of them followed
a optimum range curve which was the case
for pH iron iron and zinc and then some
of them followed a less is better which
is manganese so the less manganese do
have the higher score your soil your
soil is has the other thing to note
about this graph is that some indicators
required accounting for texture so we
adjusted them for texture and those were
the the indicators that showed
significant difference in measured
values between the between the different
textural classes and so this was a WC
organic matter active carbon and
respiration we did not develop curves
for course textured soils because we did
not have a representative sample of
course sector sold soils coming from
Colombia
so the first part of them of the of this
of the multidisciplinary study is is
understanding soil health and associated
farmers perceptions and the objectives
were to determine the Geo demographic
and environmental factors that play a
role in farmers perception of soil
health and its accuracy whether coffee
farmers have accurate perceptions of
soil health so this is and the soil
health indicators most associated with
farmers perception the statistical
analyses used here were anova four
factors influencing soil health and
farmer soil health perception accuracy a
Fisher's exact test for count data which
is a more accurate test than chi square
and the g test when you have when your
sample size is less than a thousand and
and we use that for the factors
influencing farmers soil health
perception accuracy and then we also did
a logistic regression and a principal
component analysis for the soil health
indicators most affecting farmers
perceptions so in these in these box
plots we have soil health score on the
y-axis and and the gender municipality
and membership variables so our results
actually show that female farmers have
significantly higher soil health and
male farmers yes that it they have and
someone needs to tell this to trump I
think that would be interesting to see
what his reaction would be so
furthermore we saw significant
difference among municipality Xin terms
of soil health Rosa roses having the
lowest mean and the ki bo having the
highest mean we also found that members
have significantly higher soil health
and non-member for coops which makes
sense that means that the service is
provided by the co-op have measurable
positive impact on the soil health our
results also show that coffee farmers
have correct perceptions of their soil
health these are so on the y-axis again
we have the soil health score the
the measure to a health score front from
the lab and these are the perceived soil
health so this is what they ranked most
fertile nice fur tough and on average we
did find that the most fertile what they
what they specify to be most fertile was
significantly higher than the least
fertile finally when we we were
interested in seeing what what factors
influencing influences farmers / cheb
perception of soil health when we looked
at a gender we saw that there is no
significant difference in terms of their
perception accuracy their ability to
perceive their soil high accurately did
not differ between between gender it did
not also differ between Tim Bo between
municipalities but we saw that it did
defer based on the actual soil health
meaning that far farmers who had higher
soil health were better at predicting
their other soil health and you see this
by this linear up a significant linear
model so a principal component analysis
is a great way to visualize patterns and
little lies patterns and really describe
your data it's really it was it's really
important for two reasons it helps you
detect variables and attributes that are
that have higher impact and then but it
also helps it's really useful for
dimension reduction so if you want to
achieve a parsimonious model than a PCA
would be a great way to do that and so
that's what we did we use PCA for the
logistic regressions which also show
next up to assess which indicators
affect farmers perception which affects
a farmers perception of soil health so
in the first principal component which
explains thirty four percent of the
total variability you can see that it's
very biological biological heavy so most
of the indicators are biological
and we do have some physical and then
the second principle component analysis
explains seventeen percent of the
variability and is very chemical based
so for the sake of the of having a
parsimonious model we used the the
values that represent the values with
strong correlations so those are the
ones in bold so our logistic regression
showed that organic matter of protein
iron respirations are indicators that
are most related to soil health
perception organic matter had a
significant positive relationship with
farmers perception and this makes sense
you see it in the literature organic
matter is a very effective way of
assessing your soil health when measured
data are lacking protein also had a
significant positive relationship with a
oil health perception the only way I can
explain this is protein is basically the
nitrogen bound organic compounds and
somehow the the farmers have a
perception of the importance of nitrogen
and the availability of nitrogen and
that somehow translate into being able
to perceive their soil health what's
interesting is that respiration is also
significant but it's negative and the
only way I was able to interpret this is
that the farmer seemed to took their eye
they seem to confound bit confuse are
confused between beneficial biological
activity and detrimental Peston and fat
infestation which throws throws off
their perception accuracy that's the
only way I was able to interpret this
and I'm I'm happy to hear your input at
the end of the seminar so the second
part of the second part of the study was
to assess whether soil health has an
effect on koffee kup quality so to
assess the existence and the relation
the nape the existence and the nature of
the relationship relationship between
coffee cup qual
and soil health and the soil health
indicators that our main predictors of
coffee sensorial attributes we selected
68 member for member farms that were
demarcate advisee meter quadrants and
then we did an inventory for tree
density which is a proxy proxy for shade
coverage which literature has shown to
have a positive impact on cup quality
and also elevation of the farm coffee
cherries were also sampled and the
statistical analyses used where the
correlation matrix and linear
regressions to assess the relationship
between coffee quality and soil health
and then a best subset regression for
coffee sensorial attributes to soil
health indicators so this is an example
of a coffee report so coffee is assessed
by a professional certified copper that
assesses a number of a physical physical
sensorial attributes and also granule
metric which is a series of civic test
this is a list of all of the sensorial
attributes and the physical attributes
so all the individual scores are
composited and you have a total coffee
coffee coffee square so the correlation
coefficient of coffee quality coffee
quality scores with soul health
indicators show that available water
capacity and organic matter arnette are
significantly negatively correlated with
coffee cup quality you also see a
negative correlation with phosphorus and
iron but a positive with manganese when
we run a linear regression we first use
a full linear model with all of the soil
health indicators the number of trees
and the elevation and our model did not
come out to be significant at all and we
had a negative which indicates that it's
a very poor linear model so what we did
was we did a best subset regression of
the five best predictors which are in
bold and so we extracted these and ran
their separate linear model and that's
when you start to see significance so
again you see a negative
correlation with organic matter the
estimates are negative protein
respiration has a positive estimate and
then pH and iron have a negative so so
these these findings are puzzling you
would think that you know so higher soil
health is better in in in every
dimension but after a much saught we
think that we think that coffee might
actually be very similar to grapevines
and that you don't want you don't
necessarily want a high soil health and
that additional organic matter or water
holding capacity or pH doesn't
necessarily translate to better coffee
quality and so you see again this
trade-off between between quads between
quantity and quality and where this
farmer has to decide whether to maximize
yields or achieve premium coffee quality
we're and in terms of the micronutrients
that we see her I'm I'm still haven't I
looked at the literature and I still
can't translate know how to translate
that and to don't know how that
translates into into coffee cup quality
so I best subset regression for it was
used for predicting coffee sensorial
traits so you see all of the sensorial
treats here and all of the soil health
indicators here and we noticed that iron
phosphorus and wet aggregate stability
were consistent and predicting coffee
sensorial traits they were the best
three predictors of of coffee sensorial
traits with a fairly good r-squared
value and so this is important because
it could provide an alternative to the
different sensorial assessment the third
and last part of the study involved a
comparison of the regional soil health
scoring frameworks so this where we so
we did this and in an attempt to develop
to assess the feasibility of developing
global soil health standards which is
sort of aligns with the NRC
goals of achieving national soil health
standards and so the objectives were to
assess whether different regional
scoring frameworks yield similar results
and to develop a simplified version of
the Colombian of the coffee Colombian
coffee soil health scoring framework for
this we the 223 samples were subjected
to three type of indicator and overall
soil health scoring the scores were
compared using a key test and an inter
alight inter-rater reliability test
which gives you the ICC an inter class
correlation coefficient which which
gives you the level of agreement between
the different score between the
different ranking mechanisms so if you
have an icc of point2 or below you have
poor agreement between the different
scoring mechanisms and above point 8 is
on an almost perfect agreement so
they're currently there exists three
regional scoring curves that we know of
the comprehensive assessment of soil
health that's the scoring framework
developed at cornell specific to the
northeast the Colombian coffee so health
scoring specific to kalka columbia and
the western kenya soil health scoring
functions which were developed by bianca
some of you know Bianca and colleagues
so these are what the different scoring
functions look like these are
categorized by the textural classes so
fine texture clot of soil medium texture
soil and coarse texture soil and these
are for the different regions again stnd
is the cumulative normal distribution
which is the derivative of the Gaussian
distribution and when you compare if we
take for instance if you look at wet
aggregate stability again we use the
measured values to score the wet a grits
debility in the calc of colombia's
framework but if you compare western
kenya and nor the northeast you see some
some differences in terms of them in
terms of the scoring function which is
composed of the mean and the
standard deviation so you see 58 and 43
19 and 17 so there is about a fifteen
percent difference between the between
means and if you go across the different
scoring textures you you could also see
that in medium it gets it there closer
the fairly close and the same thing for
available water capacity you see so in
this case the in medium texture soils
the the the mean for western Kenya and
and the North East are identical and
standard deviations are very similar so
these are just the different scoring
functions by textural class and by
region so additionally we also performed
we also performed a methodological
developed a methodological framework
with which we named the weighted
Columbian coffee so health scoring and
the overall soil health was computed in
this in this framework as a weighted
mean of the individuals soil indicator
scores plus texture so if you remember
the approach that we use use previously
was as an unweighted it's just a mean a
regular mean but this was weighted and
the weights were determined using a PCA
where the sum of the eigenvector vectors
of the first four principal components
were were the actual the actual weights
and so you can see here that that
biological indicator seems to have the
highest weight I know this will make
Janice really happy so and so the the
formula for the weighted overall soil
health is basically your the soil health
indicator times its weight so on over
the sum of the weight and these are the
results so the so there are two things
to note in this uh in this slide so the
t-test
the t test shows that the different that
the different scoring mechanisms yield
significantly different scores however
in some cases the ICC the inter
correlation coefficient was high which
indicates that there is actually a
strong agreement between the different
scoring mechanisms and this was the case
for what aggregate stability protein and
the overall so health scoring in other
cases the results from the t-test were
matched the results from the inter
correlation coefficient meaning that the
different scoring mechanism feel
significantly different scores and so
that the different scoring mechanism are
different and this was the case for
organic matter respiration pH and
phosphorus so the way to interpret this
discrepancy between ICC and the t-test
between in the inter correlation
coefficient and the and the t-test is
that although sometimes that she test
indicates that they are significantly
different in reality they're not because
the different scoring mechanism seemed
to generate scores that are in the same
range meaning that 99 and 94 and 96
they're all high it does it may be the
means are significantly different but
the scoring the three scoring mechanism
consistently because it's consistently
score the score the soils high and it's
the same thing for the overall soil
health they're consistently medium but
in other cases they were significantly
different so lastly given the financial
given the financial the logistical and
the resource constraints of smallholder
farmers in colombia we try to develop a
simplified and less expensive version of
a soil health assessment and we use that
this using a best subset regression so
the best stuff that regression is at
of regression that models that models
all possible that basically generates
all possible models based on a specified
number of predictors so if you if you
want one predictor it'll give you the
best model with one single predictor and
you could also choose a set of two or
three and so when you look at the best
single predictor active carbon was very
had very high predictive power and
predicting overall soil health followed
by organic matter and this is a great
finding because especially because of
the nature of the active carbon
assessment which is very easy and very
inexpensive basically all you have all
you need is some potassium permanganate
and a small field spectrophotometer and
you can have your active carbon
measurement fair in a matter of 20
minutes about and and fought it and then
if you add if you if you add other
indicators for higher predictive power
that's when you see protein and
respirations play a role and predicting
over also a health so it's it's not
until predict groups of three where you
see where you start seeing some chemical
indicators as major predictors so what
have we learned from this big
multidisciplinary study we learned that
female farmers and co-op members have
significantly higher soil health than
their counterparts farmers appear to
have correct perception of their soil
health which is not associated with
their gender or municipality but with
how healthy their soil actually is
organic matter respiration and protein
our indicators that are most related to
farmers perceptions of their soil health
we also learned that coffee quality is
significantly higher with lower soil
organic matter water quality holding
capacity and pH and iron phosphorus and
wet aggregate stability were
consistently best at predicting coffee
sensorial attributes finally in the last
part we learned that achieving global
soil health standards is possible
especially when only considering
the indicators that showed a high ICC an
inter correlation coefficient oops we
also learned that active carbon is a
great test that can highly predict
overall soil health and can be used as
in a simplified version of a soil health
assessment with that I'd like to
acknowledge my source of funding the NSF
g RFP I'd like to thank my major advisor
Harold who's been mentoring me ever
since I was a dumb undergrad and been
very patient with me Miguel Gomez who
hired me as an undergraduate research
assistant when my senior year and who
got me involved in this project and dr.
Hobbs who in whose invaluable
international work has really taken this
research to a whole nother level I also
want to thank Kirsten Kurtz and Bob from
the soil health team kirsten was the one
who taught me everything about soil
health and how to run all the samples
and I actually started when I first
started working in the soil health lab I
started with the Colombian samples and
Bob who's been the you know the behind
it all just organizing everything and
then steven perry from the cornell
statistical consulting unit who's been
giving me such difficult advice
throughout the all these parts captors
and then the story behind this slide is
actually pretty deep it's not just a
year regular thank you slide so when I
was doing the literature review for the
third part about the global soil health
standards I did so much littered review
that it was a pain in the neck and I had
to teach myself how to read dense
academic papers in four different
languages so I had to learn how to read
papers and Portuguese and Spanish and
French which thankfully I already know
and English of course I already know so
these are the languages that I used in
my literature review and that's all I
have thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu